Pourquoi ??
pour tout le monde c'est narmol ???????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????????
Est-ce que les vidéos qui viennent d'être postés sur YouTube se bloque à 301 vues pendant une journée ?
Hier je suis tombé sur une vidéo en anglais d'un mec qui a posé la question
au chef de produit du service analytique de YouTube qui explique tout et comme je sais que ça peut intéresser
ceux qui regardent pas mal de vidéos sur YouTube ou même ceux qui postent des vidéos sur YouTube
- Alors elle a fait combien ta vidéo depuis hier ?
- Euh... 301 vues
- 301 vues ! 301 vues !
- Enfin ça..ça bloque hein...
- Oh ce buzz de fou, ce buzz de malade !
Je parle à une star,je parle à une putain de star !
J'ai décidé de vous résumer cette explication... Comme ça tous le monde saura...
Hein, y a plus de "Excusez-moi, je...je savais pas, j'avais pas compris la vidéo, je parle pas anglais,
désolé, mmh, je suis désolé, vraiment.
Il faut savoir que lorsqu'une vidéo est postée sur YouTube, en faite cette vidéo est dupliquée
sur différents serveurs autour du monde, hein comme ça si vous regardez cette vidéo, par exemple depuis Paris,
et bien vous regardez une vidéo qui est présente sur des serveurs en France ou en Europe, hein pas besoin d'aller la chercher aux États-Unis, au Japon.
Et ensuite, les serveurs présents un petit peu partout sur la planète envoient l'information à YouTube,
ils disent, "Voilà, cette vidéo a été vue une fois sur mes serveurs, vas-y, allez YouTube, tu notes, allez."
L'autre chose à savoir est que YouTube différencie 2 types de vidéos, celle qui font 300 vues ou moins et celles qui font plus de 300 vues.
Donc si une vidéo fait 10 vues, 20, 30, 100, 200 jusqu'à 300, YouTube laisse le compteur augmenter normalement
Et si fais plus de 300 vues, alors YouTube estime qu'il faut vérifier les vues, alors le compteur se bloque à 301 et YouTube vérifie si il n'y a pas des robots qui s'amusent
à cliquer des milliers de fois pour faire gonfler le compteur.
C'est de la triche ! Vilain robot, je t'ai à l'oeil.
YouTube enlève alors ces fausses vues et après un peu moins d'une journée, affiche le vrai nombre au compteur.
Et là vous me dites "Oui, mais attends, parfois le compteur se bloque à 302 vues ou même plus !"
Et en plus d'avoir la même que le grand-pére dans les Simpsons, vous avez raison !
L'explication, la voici, au moment de dépasser les 300 vues c'est à dire de passer d'une vidéo où YouTube ne vérifie pas les vues à une vidéo où il vérifie,
il se peut que YouTube comptabilise plusieurs vues qui arrivent en même temps de différents serveurs.
Et comme elles sont arrivées en même temps YouTube les additionne avant de bloquer le compteur pendant une journée,
ce qui fait qu'on peut voir des nombres allant jusqu'à 320, comme 302, 303, 'fin vous les connaissez les chiffres entre 301 et 320 normalement si vous êtes allés à l'école.
Maintenant dés que vous verrez quelqu'un poster un commentaire du genre "Si toi aussi t'es le 301iéme, pouce vert !" ou alors "301 vues et 1342 commentaires !?﻿ WTF !"
Montrez-lui cette vidéo, c'est votre devoir civique.
Merci à Numberphile pour sa vidéo d'explication, c'est une chaîne YouTube qui parle de chiffres... Grosse, grosse ambiance dans la vie du mec, des chiffres quoi...
Et je vous dit à très vite !
(musique d'outro)